[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis herzlich willkommen zu den
Nachrichten was heute passiert ist
erfahren Sie in den nächsten 20 Minuten
und den Sport den hat Sven Voss schönen
guten Abend was bedeuten die Beschlüsse
des Koalitionsausschusses das ist eines
unserer Themen
geteiltes Echo auf ampelbeschlüsse
während Kanzler Scholz die Liste lobt
kritisieren Umweltschützer und
Opposition die Maßnahmen
mehr Tempo bei Einwanderung die
Bundesregierung einigt sich auf neuen
Gesetzentwurf um Fachkräfte aus dem
Ausland anzuwerben
und royaler Glanz in Berlin König
Charles III und seine Frau Camilla
beginnen ihren dreitägigen Staatsbesuch
in Deutschland
was ist von den Ergebnissen des
marathon-koalitionsausschusses zu halten
der Kanzler hat sie heute verteidigt
denn es gibt viel Kritik es geht um
folgendes den einbauklimafreundliche
Heizungen Änderungen bei den
klimaschutzregeln ein schnelleren Ausbau
von Autobahnstrecken aber auch um mehr
Geld für die Bahn wir schauen uns die
Beschlüsse genauer an Julia Schröter
die Koalition will Tempo machen beim
Thema Verkehr das Schienennetz soll
modernisiert und erweitert werden das
Geld dafür soll zum Teil aus einer
höheren Lkw-Maut kommen außerdem ist
vereinbart 144 autobahnprojekte
schneller zu realisieren mit
zweifelhaftem Effekt fürs Klima der
Autobahnbau hat weder was mit
Klimaschutz zu tun noch was mit besserem
mobilitätsoptionen denn die
mobilitätsforschung weiß mittlerweile
dass neue Autobahn einfach neuen Verkehr
induzieren ohne die Erreichbarkeit
letztendlich zu erhöhen beim Thema
Heizung bleibt es dabei neue Heizungen
sollen ab kommenden Jahr möglich zu 65%
mit erneuerbaren Energien betrieben
werden auch heizen mit Biomasse oder
klimaneutral hergestellten Wasserstoff
soll möglich sein beim Wasserstoff aber
haben Experten Zweifel technisches ist
schon wirklich man müsste quasi andere
Gasbrenner einbauen erste Hersteller
auch schon solche Produkte an aber es
macht nur Sinn aber tatsächlich neue
Heizung in stalliert
deswegen Nischen Lösung weil wir diesen
Wasserstoff gerade den Grünen
Wasserstoff aus Erneuerbaren Stellen
brauchen wer eine neue klimafreundliche
Heizung einbauen muss das finanziell
aber nicht stemmen kann soll bei den
Kosten unterstützt werden wie und in
welcher Höhe da bleibt die Ampel Waage
vereinbart sind außerdem Änderungen am
Klimaschutzgesetz bislang wurden die
verschiedenen Bereiche Stromerzeugung
Industrie Verkehr Gebäude und
Landwirtschaft mit ihren co2-vorgaben
getrennt betrachtet künftig soll es so
sein dass verfehlte Ziele in einem
Sektor von einem anderen ausgeglichen
werden können
wichtig ist dass wir die Sektoren und
auch die Ministerien damit dafür
zuständig sind nicht aus der
Verantwortung erlassen sie müssen weiter
zuständig sein für Klimaschutz sie
müssen auch entsprechenden Druck
ausgeübt gegenüber stehen das ist ganz
ganz wichtig die Beschlüsse der
Ampelkoalition im Detail sind noch viele
Fragen offen
die Opposition reagiert kritisch sowohl
die linke als auch die AFD warnen wegen
der geplanten Erhöhung der Lkw-Maut vor
steigenden Verbraucherpreisen und auch
Umweltverbände sind alles andere als
glücklich mit dem Beschlüssen so spricht
WWF Deutschland von einem Zitat
Frontalangriff auf das Klimaschutz
gesetzt Patricia Wiedemeier über die
Reaktionen
betont gelassen und gut gelaunt geben
sie sich die drei Koalitionspartner in
der ersten Reihe als habe es keine
endlosen Debatten keine sitzungsnacht
ohne Schlaf gegeben in der
regierungsbefragung verteidigt der
Kanzler das Reformpaket kündigt die
Modernisierung der Infrastruktur der
Bahn der Gebäude an
der Stillstand der letzten Jahrzehnte
den wir konservativer Politik zu
verdanken haben ist endgültig beendet
jetzt kommt Tempo in Deutschland die
Opposition kritisiert dass die
Kindergrundsicherung nicht besprochen
wurde dass es weiterhin Unklarheit beim
Thema heizungsaustausch gibt und dass
das Klimaschutzgesetz aufgeweicht wird
wir haben gemeinsam in der großen
Koalition in Klimaschutzgesetz
beschlossen um die Verbindlichkeit bei
den Klimazielen sicherzustellen mit
ihrem neuen Partnern wollen sie die
wesentlichen Fortschritte dabei jetzt
wieder abschaffen das Klimaschutzgesetz
aufweichen statt des einzuhalten wie
können Sie das verantworten man habe das
Gesetz nicht aufgeweicht sondern
weiterentwickelt verteidigt sich
daraufhin Olaf Scholz die Reaktion auf
die gestrigen Beschlüsse sehr
unterschiedlich so begrüßt die
Wirtschaft unter anderem die Erhöhung
der Lkw-Maut zum einen ist es sinnvoll
dass man ein Lkw-Maut erhöht und damit
die Schiene finanziert man macht das LKW
fahren die Straße teurer und generiert
damit gleichzeitig Mittel um die Schiene
auszubauen heftige Kritik dagegen von
allen Umweltverbänden der Bundeskanzler
Olaf Scholz kann seinen selbst der
verliehenen Titel als klimakanzler jetzt
wirklich in Schimpf und Schande abgeben
er hat sich offenbar in diesen
Verhandlungen nicht hinter das
Klimaschutzgesetz gestellt und jetzt
haben wir ein Gesetz das ist nur noch
Stückwerk kein Stückwerk sondern ein
großes Werkstück das hatte Scholz
gestern versprochen doch es gibt bisher
wenig Konkretes viel Arbeit also für die
Abgeordneten im Gesetzgebungsverfahren
der nächsten Wochen
Patricia Wiedemeier sPD Grüne oder FDP
welche Partei hat sich denn am meisten
durchgesetzt
ja wie so oft stellen sich ja immer alle
als Gewinner da aber wenn man genau
hinschaut dann muss man sagen dass die
FDP mehr durchgesetzt hat als die Grünen
sie mussten einige Kröten schlucken bei
der planungsbeschleunigung zum Beispiel
wollten Sie diese vor allem für die
Schiene jetzt gilt es auch für rund 140
autobahnprojekte genau das wollten die
Grünen verhindern dass jetzt am Rande
Solarfelder gebaut werden ein schwacher
Trost und noch schwerer vermittelbar für
die grüne Basis im Verkehrsbereich der
ja bis jetzt alle Klimaziele verfehlt
wird sich nicht viel ändern da andere
Sektoren jetzt ausgleichen dürfen also
das bisherige Klimaschutzgesetz
aufgeweicht wird es seien halt auf zwei
gegen eins sprich SPD und FDP gegen die
Grünen hört man mehr sei in dieser
Koalition nicht möglich hat ein
enttäuschter Vizekanzler Harbeck am
Abend getwittert es sei ein Kompromiss
Papier dabei sind die Maus keinen Faden
ab also von Koalitionsfrieden keine Spur
kein Wunder wenn es immer wieder vor
allem ein Partner ist der Kompromiss se
machen muss danke für diese Einschätzung
Patricia wiedemann
die Staatsschulden sind so hoch wie nie
rund 2,37 Billionen Euro waren es Ende
Dezember 2% mehr als noch ein Jahr zuvor
pro Kopf macht das umgerechnet gut
28.000 Euro während fast alle
Bundesländer ihre Schulden leicht senken
konnten sind sie bei Kommunen und dem
Bund angestiegen unter anderem wegen der
Kosten von corona-pandemie und
Energiekrise
der Warnstreik am Montag könnte nur ein
Vorgeschmack gewesen sein in Potsdam
entscheidet sich wohl in den nächsten
Stunden ob es in den Kommunen und im
Bund einen großen Arbeitskampf im
öffentlichen Dienst geben wird Verdi und
Beamtenbund fordern angesichts der hohen
Inflation
10,5% mehr Lohn mindestens aber 500 Euro
mehr im Monat bei einer Laufzeit von 12
Monaten die Arbeitgeber bieten bisher
fünf Prozent und einer Einmalzahlung bei
einer Laufzeit von 27 Monaten da liegt
man also weit auseinander zum Stand der
Dinge anti-
die verhandlungsführerinnen seit Montag
um Kompromisse und einen guten
Tarifabschluss für die 2,5 Millionen
Beschäftigten des öffentlichen Dienstes
die Nebenkosten zu Hause steigen ins
Unermessliche Strom Gas alles verteurer
Lebensmittelpreise steigen
ja man hat so langsam auch Angst dass
man irgendwann nicht mehr finanzieren
kann mehr Geld für ihre Angestellten das
ist vor allem für Kommunen eine
Herausforderung auch der Bürgermeister
von Jüterbog muss ständig abwägen er
weiß Personal ist seine wichtigste
Ressource dagegen stehen aber jede Menge
Investitionen als kleine Kommune wird
nun gesagt entscheide ob sie die Kita
baust die dringend notwendig ist ob der
dir die Schule leistet weil die aus
allen Nähten platzen ich habe zu Zuzug
ich habe Ukraine zu versorgen und so
weiter und entscheide ob du diese Dinge
machst oder ob der Personal angemessen
vergütet
angemessene Vergütung die hart erkämpft
werden muss wie sich auch heute wieder
zeigt die Atmosphäre ist ziemlich
frostig beide Parteien liegen immer noch
weit auseinander Ringen um eine Einigung
in letzter Minute aber auch ein
Scheitern ist denkbar dann käme der
Schlichter oder es würde eine vierte
Verhandlungsrunde anberaumt dann würden
allerdings auch möglicherweise wieder
streiksdrohen so oder so hier in Potsdam
stellt man sich auf eine lange Nacht ein
Fachkräfte werden ja händeringend in
Deutschland gesucht die Bundesregierung
will daher mehr Arbeitskräfte aus
Ländern außerhalb der EU gewinnen sie
sollen schneller und einfacher als
bisher ins Land kommen können das sieht
ein Gesetzesentwurf vor der heute vom
Kabinett gebilligt wurde er muss jetzt
noch vom Bundestag beraten werden mehr
dazu von lass Bohnensack
lange wusste die 25-Jährige Tier aus
Madagaskar nicht ob sie in Deutschland
arbeiten kann mit der Ausbildung die sie
gerade in Erfurt absolviert hofft sie
auf eine konkrete Arbeit und
Bleibeperspektive wenn meine Ausbildung
fertig ist dann bekomme ich so eine
befristete Vertrag und dann ja kann ich
lange bleiben der Arbeitskräfte Bedarf
verschärft sich während 2013 eine Stelle
durchschnittlich 2,6 Monate unbesetzt
blieb waren es im letzten Jahr bereits
4,6 Monate
2013 kamen auf eine offene Stelle sechs
Arbeitslose
2022 nur noch 1,8
wenn wir jetzt nicht alle Register
ziehen wir werden alle Register ziehen
dann droht Arbeits- und Fachkräftemangel
zu einer dauerhaften Wachstumsbremse für
Deutschland zu werden das neue
Einwanderungsrecht setzt an drei Punkten
an bei der Qualifikation reicht künftig
ein anerkannter Abschluss um in allen
Branchen arbeiten zu können ausländische
Fachkräfte mit ausreichender
Berufserfahrung können künftig auch ohne
Abschluss bei uns arbeiten und die den
ein Potenzial attestiert wird bekommen
die Chance über einen Punktesystem ein
Einwanderungsrecht ist das was die
konservative Seite nie verstanden hat
ist steuern und Ordnung steuern und
Ordnung wir entscheiden jetzt zu uns
kommt und wie die Qualifikation
geschafft werden doch Fachkräfte sollen
nicht nur aus dem Ausland gewonnen
werden parallel zum neuen
Einwanderungsgesetz will die Regierung
mit einer aus- und
weiterbildungsgarantie auch hierzulande
mehr Arbeitnehmer qualifizieren
nach Karlsruhe zum
Bundesverfassungsgericht dagegen ist
heute um im Ausland geschlossene
Kinderehen seit 2017 sind die in
Deutschland automatisch unwirksam und
das bleibt auch so allerdings fordern
die Richterinnen und Richter vom
gesetzgeberänderungen betroffene sollen
Anspruch auf Unterhalt bekommen wie nach
einer Scheidung und sobald beide
volljährig sind soll das Paar die Ehe
auf Wunsch auch nach deutschem Recht
weiterführen können
in die Ukraine dort gibt es wieder mehr
Kämpfe rund um das Atomkraftwerk
saporicia der Chef der Internationalen
Atomenergiebehörde grossy besuchte heute
die von Russland kontrollierte Anlage
erwarte vor einer Katastrophe
saboricia ist ja das größte AKW in
Europa ein Unfall dort könnte schlimmere
Folgen haben als er nuklear-unfall von
Tschernobyl 1986 das damals havarierte
Kraftwerk hatten russische Truppen
Anfang des Krieges ebenfalls besetzt die
Befreiung jetzt sich dieser Tage zum
ersten Mal unsere reporterin Anne Brühl
war dort
Oxana püschner führt Besucher durch die
Sperrzone zeigt uns den roten Wald den
Ort der bei der Katastrophe die höchste
Strahlung abbekommen hat ausgerechnet
hier heben die Russen während der
Besatzung Schützengräben aus nutzen das
Gelände auch um die Kiefer Vororte ihr
PIN und Butcher mit Raketen zu
beschießen
sie waren sicher dass die Ukraine sie
hier nicht angreifen
wir sind an einem der gefährlichsten
Orte der Welt die Strahlenbelastung nach
dem Atomunfall von 1986 ist immer noch
erhöht ein Sarkophag bedeckt heute den
Unglücksreaktor
jedes atomobjekt wird für das Leben in
Friedenszeiten und nicht für den Krieg
gebaut und wenn wir den Reaktor oder das
Lager sprengen würden dann hätte das
katastrophale Folgen
russische Panzer in Tschernobyl gleich
am ersten Kriegstag besetzen Putins
Soldaten das stillgelegte Atomkraftwerk
200 Arbeiter sind plötzlich Gefangene
sie müssen sicherstellen dass keine
Strahlung Austritt schon bald aber reist
die Verbindung zu den
Überwachungsgeräten ab die
Stromversorgung wird zeitweise
unterbrochen nach gut einem Monat ziehen
die Russen ab auch aus der Stadt
schernoby Mahnmal für das Leid so vieler
leid dass der Krieg jetzt wieder in die
Ukraine gebracht hat
wenn kein Ende in Sicht ist dann ist es
sehr schwer Leben mit der atomaren
Bedrohung und dem Krieg in Tschernobyl
müssen sie mit beidem fertig werden
und mehr zur Sorge um den ukrainischen
Reaktor und das Trauma von Tschernobyl
sehen Sie im auslandsjournal um 22:15
Uhr
in Frankreich ist es am Rande der
Massenproteste gegen die Rentenreform
gestern erneut zur Ausschreitungen
gekommen
Krawalle und Sachbeschädigungen gab es
am Abend in mehreren Städten wie hier in
Paris bei den gewaltsamen Zusammenstößen
erlitten laut Innenministerium 175
Polizisten Verletzungen etwa 200
Menschen wurden festgenommen
wegen der Proteste konnte König Charles
nicht viel geplant nach Frankreich
reisen und so ist das Ziel der ersten
Auslandsreise des neuen Königs fares
Deutschland Fans sollen die Straßen in
Berlin Hände schütteln und kleine
Geschenke König Schals III und Gattin
Camilla gaben sich die Ehre Andreas
Künast über den Besuch der britischen
Royals
so hat sich Berlin noch nie aufgestellt
dass Maximalmaß pompt der Bundesrepublik
vorm Brandenburger Tor
die Ehrenformation vom Bundespräsidenten
Flaggen Fähnchen und die Ansage keine
selfies bitte mit dem König
das Charles noch vor seiner Krönung in
die EU reist und nicht etwa in ein
kommentsland darf durchaus politisch
verstanden werden drei Jahre nach dem
brexit
erstes Thema auf Wunsch seiner Majestät
ein Gespräch über die Klimapolitik
indem wir heute hier zusammenkommen
senden wir auch eine Botschaft an unsere
Bürgerinnen und Bürger wir sehen die
dramatische Dringlichkeit im Kampf gegen
den Klimawandel und wir nehmen diese
Aufgabe an dann Pflanzen die Herren
Staatsoberhäupter einen Baum auf die
feine englische Art
das Charles mit salut Schüssen und von
Eurofightern begrüßt worden war nehmen
selbst Monarchie Kritiker hin die
geplante Rede im Parlament aber weckt
Kritik gerade im Bundestag wo es ja um
die Repräsentanz des Volkes geht der
Bevölkerung dort ein Monarchen sprechen
zu lassen finde ich leicht aus der Zeit
gefallen
sie sind ein sehr netter König zumindest
der besuchsanfang war für Berliner
Verhältnisse impulsiv
und mit dem König ist auch unsere
Großbritannien kosmonentin Hilke
Petersen nach Berlin gekommen Hilfe
stärkt der Besuch des Königs die
deutsch-britischen Beziehung
das ist das Ziel dieses Besuchs und das
ist interessant vor dem Hintergrund dass
die Regierung sich natürlich Ziele für
Staatsbesuche vom König wünscht und die
britische Regierung braucht im Moment
die Europäer für ein paar politische
Vorhaben tatsächlich Bundespräsident
Steinmeier hat heute hier hinter mir im
Schloss Bellevue darauf hingewiesen dass
dieser Tag exakt vor sechs Jahren der
war dass die an dem die Briten ihr
Austritt gesucht bei der EU eingereicht
haben und er hat gesagt wir schlagen ein
neues Kapitel auf hinter mir hier im
Schloss Bellevue geht jetzt gleich das
Staatsbankett los 130 Gäste sind geladen
darunter Verwandte Cousins aus dem
deutschen Adel ehemalige
Bundespräsidenten Gauck und Köhler
angela Merkel ist eingeladen und auch
Campino von den Toten Hosen kommt der
hat einen Frack getragen denn das ist
hier heute Abend die kleiderehrung die
Kleiderordnung zu Ehren der Gäste
dankeschön
rund 40 Mal hat Charles bereits
Deutschland als Prinz besucht jetzt das
erste Mal als König ein Portrait über
den 74-Jährigen auf dem Weg zum
britischen Bereichen können Sie in
unserer ZDF heute Apple lesen mit vielen
kleinen Filmen und anikdoten
und nun kommen wir zum Fußball die
Niederlage der deutschen Mannschaft
gestern macht ja ein bisschen
nachdenklich Sven oder ja ging mir auch
so Jana vor allem die ersten 25 Minuten
im Spiel gegen Belgien haben nicht nur
den Bundestrainer frustriert so eine
Anfangsphase muss laut Hansi Flick
einmalig bleiben auch eine bessere
zweite Hälfte des DFB-Teams konnte die
Niederlage nicht verhindern
der Bundestrainer wirkt entgeistert in
der Anfangsphase 10 Minuten sind noch
nicht vorbei da führt Belgien schon zwei
zu null durch romelu Lukaku das hat was
von Klassenunterschied
ja also ich glaube wenn wir so wie die
ersten 15 30 Minuten spielen dann dann
ist fast jede Mannschaft der Welt eine
Nummer zu groß Leon Goretzka muss dann
verletzt vom Feld das Team wird umgebaut
und fängt sich Niklas Füllkrug er hat
Elfmeter zum eins zu zwei kurz vor der
Pause danach macht Kevin de Bruyne das
dritte Tor für die Gäste die
ersatzgeschwächte DFB elf tröstet sich
mit der besseren zweiten Hälfte in der
Serie zum zweiten drei entstand trifft
deswegen glaube ich schon auch wenn das
Ergebnis heute negativ gelaufen ist dass
er das ist die Idee dahinter wie ich
sehr gut war bei Belgiens neu im Trainer
Domenico tedesco stimmt Idee und
Ergebnis zwei Spiele zwei Siege gute
Einstand
und wir bleiben beim Fußball guter
Ausgangsposition für die Frauen des FC
Bayern München in der Champions League
nach dem 1:0 zu Hause gegen den WFC
Arsenal kann der FCB heute in London das
Halbfinale klar machen dass
Selbstbewusstsein könnte kaum größer
sein
aber die
chwendet 1:07
Gehrung später reaktionsschnell auf der
Linie
das Team von Cheftrainer Alexander
Strauß braucht in London so zumindest
ein Unentschieden um sich einen der vier
Plätze im Halbfinale zu sichern ich
glaube dass wir so wie wir in der
Verfassung wie wir gerade sind können
wir es echt schaffen weit zu kommen und
auch den möglichen Halbfinalgegner Paris
oder Wolfsburg danach zu schlagen aber
Arsenal spielte in der zweiten Halbzeit
es Hinspiels auf Augenhöhe die
Bäuerinnen haben so mit Glück gewonnen
dass sie es besser können müssen sie
heute Abend zeigen
aus Jana
und diese Lottozahlen wurden gezogen die
Gewinnzahlen lauten 2 19 37 40 43 48
Superzahl ist die 5 weitere Gewinnzahlen
finden sie auf lotto.zdf.de und sind ZDF
Text auf Seite 57
kräftige Schauer und Gewitter ziehen
morgen über uns hinweg und Freitag kommt
Sturm mehr zum Wetter gleich von Katja
horneffer das heute journal läuft um
21:45 Uhr mit Maria das Slomka tschüss
[Musik]
guten Abend das Tiefdruck Zentrum von
tief lasse können Sie hier kaum erkennen
aber seine Fronten er sieht die
Warmfront und dann die Kaltfront über
uns hinweg das bedeutet kräftige
Regenfälle am Alpenrand und auch Schauer
und Gewitter und morgen Abend kommt dann
schon ein nächstes stürmisches tief
namens Markus über den britischen Inseln
an heute Nacht fällt in der Osthälfte
Regen und im Westen kann es dann am
frühen Morgen schon die ersten Gewitter
geben der Winter kommt aus südlichen
Richtung und das wird noch meine milde
Nacht mit Tiefsttemperatur von 13 Grad
am Oberrhein und vier Grad in der
Oberpfalz und morgen gibt's ein kräftige
Schauer und Gewitter zwischendurch aber
auch mal Sonne länger regnet es am
Alpenrand und auch in Schleswig-Holstein
und der Wind ist schon recht kräftig zum
Teil sogar stürmisch über den
Mittelgebirge und der kommt aus Südwest
so wird es auch morgen noch mal ein
milder Tag die Temperaturen an der
Nordsee liegen so um die 12 Grad am
Oberrhein werden es 18 Grad und diese
stürmische tiefen Modus wird uns dann am
Freitag einmal überqueren es gibt also
viel Wind in der Mitte und im Süden
Deutschlands am Samstag dreht der Wind
an der Ostseeküste bereits auf Nordost
und am Sonntag liegen die
Höchsttemperaturen dann nur noch
zwischen 5 und 11 Grad guten Abend